they're always really nice to us when it
doesn't matter
you know but when it really does matter
they i mean i think we
actually did see them cross the rubicon
during the
shortly after the election during the
litigation where
some hipster rasputin this guy with the
nose ring in silicon valley
de-platformed the duly elected sitting
president of the united states
regardless of which thing happened in
the election the guy's the president and
this
oligarch took him out and he could take
him out and it wasn't just him
they all worked in concert with one
another and i i
sort i mean this is actually a lot of
the topic of my my book my
second book but my first book with words
which is called speechless and
it's it's about this this problem of
free speech
what is it you know i think it gets back
to your point tim which is so right the
reason that i think we keep losing
ground
we lose grounded maybe they pat us on
the head and they're nice to us when it
doesn't matter but
we still keep losing is because we
are only thinking about ourselves we're
only thinking about this
individualist hyper-individualist
ideology we're only thinking about the
debate as one between
free speech and censorship when i don't
think it's i think it's a debate between
competing sets of standards
and it actually leads us into a trap
this i think conservatives fall for this
trap i think
the left understands free speech way
better than conservatives do
i think we kid ourselves when we pretend
that we understand it better
and the trap is this political
correctness
tries to destroy the old order that's
all it wants to do once all the old
rituals all the ultra it wants to get
rid of it
and conservatives react one of two ways
either this we go along with it that's
what the squishes do and they say oh who
cares
oh the squid it's not a big deal
actually drag queen story hours a
blessing of liberty
yeah whatever you know it's that kind of
thing and then but the second
way we respond which i think we we've
probably all fallen into this camp at
various times myself certainly included
is we'll say okay no i'm not going along
because i'm a free speech absolutist i'm
a
free expression whatever absolutist and
so
no one can ever tell me that this is
better than that or this is more true
than that
i'm going to be able to do whatever i
want and so you
disavow standards altogether either way
either way the radical leftists get what
they want
i think i am one of the worst possible
things for conservatives
in the long run in that and i've i've
maintained this
for years they like so when i first
started
doing youtube yeah the people at google
that i was working with were like their
liberal
you know liaisons and stuff and i know a
lot of people at google yeah
and then eventually they started calling
me a centrist i was i was
you know and they say you know you're
changing and i'm like my videos from
2014 are of the same opinion i did a
video in 2014 about you know a
segregated graduation ceremony i thought
was wrong i think we should segregate
yeah my opinions are relatively the same
in fact i've become more liberty minded
and actually i take the political
compass test
i'll actually move further to the left
ideologically yeah but they keep calling
me
they first say tim's oh tim's a liberal
he's not a progressive
then they say he's a centrist yeah now
they're calling me right wing you're a
fascist
so well they've never they don't call me
fascist right that's why i say i'm one
of the worst things for conservatives
i think the reason why youtube likes
what i do
and i have a good go of things when they
ban conservatives
they want to make sure that
conservatives stay on platform
and so there has to be something that's
semi-acceptable to some conservatives
there are a lot of people who are
conservatives who like i disagree with
tim but you know i'll watch his show
yeah but what happens when they get rid
of crowder right then the people who are
on who are on youtube
who remain will be like i'll still watch
tim but then they're going to get a more
liberal viewpoint
that's rotating the wheel and spinning
and pushing the overton one to the left
i don't literally think i'm the worst
thing for conservatives i think we do
good work here to try and be fair to
everybody
but they're trying to rotate the wheel
so that centrist becomes far right
and actual liberals become conservative
and then that is
so perceptive i mean because basically
what what you're seeing happening in
real time is what reagan said
i didn't leave my party my party left me
you're seeing that happen to you but
you're also
you're self-aware enough to realize
they're doing it with you you you
actually are the evidence of that
overton window
shifting and well that's the point
though is the overton window right which
is
i think that sometimes conservatives and
i've been guilty of this myself
years past we pretend
that there is a thing total absolute 100
free speech
that's the american way isn't it no it
never has been
it never will be there have always been
broad swaths of speech in america that
you're not allowed to say
sedition fraud fighting words
why and why obscenity actually is a
really big one garland
george seven words can't say on tv seven
words you can't say on tv now you have
to say those words
but why were you not allowed to say
those things because all of those things
fraud obscenity our speech that
undermines speech
at least in the understanding of the
founding fathers and i think
of the smartest people on this issue for
all time
in the 1950s you'd get canceled for
being a communist today
you will get canceled for not being a
communist
there's always going to be some kind of
cancelling they're always going to be
things you can't say and you can't do
but look at how that has shifted look at
the way that
in in the 1950s if you burned an
american flag you might be taken up on
the smith act
what was the smith act smith act was an
anti-communist right
but you know we've had these sorts of
bills going back to the founding not not
particularly with communism but with all
sorts of subversive ideologies
today if you you could go out you could
burn a flag in the streets
and the left has gotten the
conservatives to defend them
to celebrate that nothing more american
than burning the american flag that's
that's a big cultural victory for the
left but you know here's the thing
i've always been a liberal and i think
people have a right to free speech so
long as their own property they can burn
it
now like i said they're trying to call
me a conservative they're right the
people on twitter are like tim's are
right winger you right wingers
now the funny thing is i got called left
by a right wing outlet
and right by a left wing outlet and so i
just like screenshot it and put it on
twitter and i'm like i have found the
singularity like
people don't realize centrism exists and
they think centrism is like
agreeing with the worst parts of like
you know the left and right no it's like
agreeing that some people on the right
have it right some people have some good
points
there's something very conservative by
the way about centrism i don't mean i'm
i'm slightly to the right of genghis
khan
but there's there's something really
something really berkey in something
really conservative about centrism
it's it's actually what i i tried to do
this this was kind of the
beginning idea for my book is i
wanted to take the left-wing
intellectuals seriously
because you know we do this all the time
on the right we say oh you know the
critical theorists there i hate them
remarks or you know
gramsci or whoever whoever it is marcus
right
but no one actually engages with them
and the thing about those guys
those radical left theorists is they're
super
duper intelligent which is why they've
been so successful
and we keep losing you know i love
quoting marks when i can
to like prove points about like liberty
for instance
yeah to be honest there's only one i can
actually reference and it's
under no pretext shall arms and
ammunition be surrendered the working
class should
uh should um frustrate this by force if
necessary
and so i tweeted under no pretext shall
the right to keep and bear arms be
infringed
with a picture of an m16 on a trans flag
because i'm like freedom liberty
and guns there is no q if marx were
alive today he would be on the alt-right
there's no question about it
he would i'm serious i'm not even joe i
mean there's right he's gonna be like a
biden
liberal establishment neolib i don't
think so no he was racist
yeah and uh and he was yeah it's
funny he really and he really didn't
like the jews even though he was you
know he was
he's he's a racist anti-semite who
believed in owning guns
it's closer to alt-right than you're
going to get anybody on the left
actually you know we were talking about
sheamus from freedom too because he was
just here but he has a very very popular
cartoon you may have seen
where the woke left desperate to stop
the nazis
use a time machine to bring world war ii
soldiers to the future
and then when they try explaining to
them what's happening the soldiers
so they're like you know our president
is a fascist
and then they give him a brochure and
then the world war two soldiers go
oh my what your president supports
gay marriage it's like the world war ii
soldiers were ridiculously conservative
yeah
well certainly by the i mean by the
standards of today like willing grace
was ridiculously conservative
because because hemingway describes this
in sun also rises he's talking about how
you go bankrupt
so how's you go how'd you go bankrupt
and the guy says gradually
then suddenly and that you know we've
kind of gone through this gradually
period
which is i don't know 60s 70s 80s
it seems to me like we are very much in
the suddenly phase
i mean just think about we went from
barack obama and hillary clinton saying
marriage is a sacred bond between a man
and a woman
to if you don't castrate your child
you're a bigot
come on trans the kids bigot we did that
in like six years or something
this is this is where i think an
interesting thing happens
you're substantially more conservative
than i am but i
as a you know as far as a traditional
american liberal over the past couple
decades
yeah have a red line on what i think
doesn't doesn't make sense
so i was a big fan of tulsi gabbard yeah
and what did tulsi gabbard say she said
safe
legal but rare when it came to abortion
right and so that was where the the
liberals were 10 years before
so something happened and i think it has
a lot to do with social media
where well it's a combination of things
but do you think social media played a
huge role in the rapid
leftist leftization or whatever you want
to call it of the establishment
to where like some i i
i voted for obama the first time because
of the war issue i didn't want to vote
for the second time i considered myself
to be
you know younger anarchy leftists got
older kind of learned some
some things then was like i'm a liberal
then i got older and i was like actually
i should open my mind and listen to you
know people of all different backgrounds
and i see these things happening with
like uh it was
i think michelle wolf is her name the
comedian yeah where she goes on
her netflix show and she goes you get an
abortion and you can and i was like that
scares me yeah
because like the argument that i
understood growing up from a very
liberal family was
safe legal rare yeah like it was it was
supposed to be like a medical thing
where your doctor is here to help you
you know why it changed and i actually
have sympathy for the left on this as to
why it changed
because everybody recognized that you
know it's
abortion is not a thing you want you
don't want more of it right i mean
everybody even if you you support
legal abortion you don't you don't like
go celebrate it
but they but they do now and it's
because the legal and rare issue
raised this question of what is an
abortion if it has any moral similarity
to murder then it shouldn't be legal
if it if it isn't morally similar to
murder then there's no reason for it to
be rare
and i i think they couldn't stand the
kind of
gnawing shame of that and and there's a
lot of different places the shame could
come from
and they couldn't it had to be never
with the left
do they merely want you to tolerate them
never do they merely want you to accept
them you must
affirm them you must validate every
single
desire that they want and so very
quickly on a whole host of issues not
just abortion
you go from hey i have this disordered
desire please just
tolerate it two if you don't take your
kids
to watch me do this thing and you don't
put it on nickelodeon shows
then you're a bigot and there's no true
equity in the world thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time